[Music]
hey jason do you smoke uh marijuana
sometimes i know i don't look like i
would smoke marijuana but what would you
say you totally look like a pothead no i
don't
you look more like an alcohol guy he's
getting you back why are you doing that
what are you telling you talking crow's
feet dog get out of here dog yeah but
that's not racist
[Laughter]
yeah i like to smoke a little bit
sometimes but it's just um i i don't
like that when people are pressuring you
to smoke so much do i mean we're going
to pressure you today it's just i don't
want a taxi taxi yeah like because
sometimes um i will smoke with my
friends and then you'll be like hold it
in and then you pass it to all of your
friends before you breathe it out and
you believe that some [ __ ] really
young weed smoking stuff that's trauma
dude yeah that's right we smoking trauma
yeah i get paranoid yeah we won't do
that too that's why you you pretend like
you're holding your breath and then you
exhale for your nose they see it they go
what the [ __ ] is that that's [ __ ]
smoke
well they said that's some really
efficient weed smoking groups uh a
friend are they in high school
it's just him in a bunch of high school
guys it was in high school when i smoked
like that but now i just smoke a little
bit sometimes yeah
well there's uh a uh
i want to say large i was gonna say a
large group of people a whole [ __ ]
town oh wow had to be evacuated because
they did the taxi after yeah
the whole town they all passed out
everyone's in high school in the whole
town
it's a high school town so residents of
a town in colombia
became engulfed by a huge marijuana
cloud after a controlled burning became
uncontrolled dude they did that on
purpose
you think so oh for sure you don't have
to burn it you could like make hemp like
hemp stuff oh we got a pro here what
else
so you're the police right you're the
police you [ __ ] confiscate off like
what is that 1.5 tons of marijuana and
tons yeah now they you could uh give the
weed to workers and they could make beds
they could make
bed sheets
they could make pillows
dang blankets they just
you don't think the workers will go
no i'm going to sell this yeah yeah once
they take their eyes off it it's in the
factory you can't take it oh you put in
the factories
factory workers have high standards
factory
i thought it was just straight away it's
one way in what about the factories
like this
they weren't naked
yeah they were naked like american yeah
gangster
yeah you gotta be naked yeah yeah at the
hemp factory factory everybody works
naked at the hemp factory
you don't have to burn it dude why do
you burn it because it's the best way to
get rid of it
because then it doesn't exist anymore
because what if they can't throw it away
what if they take it to the factory wait
do they not make stuff they make i mean
hemp is not the same thing as the as the
weed that we smoke
most temp is uh made from the male plant
and it's not um potent that's what i
said
it just sounded a little more taiwanese
i said that earlier yeah
i like the way you said it
i got a better idea you get all my
[ __ ] weed if they don't want to burn
it oh my [ __ ] we put it in a giant
pillowcase
you seal the top you put a string next
to a helicopter you take it into the
ocean and you brew the [ __ ]
that's the boston team
everybody's going to be swimming the
next day it's called a tuna paranoid
and you see the happiest fish just
thinking about a giant tea bag
with marijuana in it being dipped in the
ocean by a
helicopter bit all the sea creatures are
now conspiracy theorists and [ __ ]
so uh yeah so it was initially feared
that the fire was just a regular fire
that was uh this was in medellin
but soon people obviously realize that
it didn't smell like your average
regular fire blaze
oh yeah it did
exactly it did turn out the police tried
to do a controlled burning of seized
weed but it proved to be very very
difficult because everyone's all high
now because they're smelling this wait
so here's the
time i have a dumb question i have a
dumb question because i don't know [ __ ]
uh
can you really get high from like
something like that happening yeah
tons of weed being burned absolutely
as high as if you were smoking it you
know like hot boxing a car yeah so like
if you ever had that friend i always
thought that was just like theatrical i
don't know if you ever had that friend
that like didn't want to smoke weed so
then all the homes you'd be like let's
just hop box the car so you go into a
car you put all the windows you know
what i mean you just [ __ ] took out an
entire joint or in the car so there's
nothing but smoke by the time so the guy
who's not even smoking it will get as
high as everyone else and sex for sure
yes well as long as there's enough in
the air you ever been to a certain rap
concert sometimes you got the right rap
concert like my wife actually got kind
of second hand hi at like a action
bronson concert and the whole time she
was like oh my god that sounds like a
bunch of weed and food yeah action
boston yeah yeah pizza
or if you ever like youtube uh any of
the news reporters that go out to these
types of things that they're trying to
like uh report the news they'd be like
in a blaze and a mirror one ball and
then halfway through they start cracking
up because they literally are just
you're just inhaling all the potency in
an area i'm talking like in the air like
70 of the air is like marijuana you know
what i mean
and it's not like you're taking a hit
and you're passing you're like breathing
the substance yeah you know what i'm
saying
getting constant i don't like to smoke
in public anymore i only smoke indoors
it's dangerous i don't like to look at
strangers anymore
when i'm played out you feel like they
know it's old school
i feel like the amount of people that
smoke in public now is so
especially in l.a
i'm walking on the street and it's just
like you're just you're just literally
you have a blunt in your mouth it
definitely doesn't look as cool anymore
yeah it's not as like like the
impression of in the 90s and 80s and
like in 70s sometimes i just have a join
my ear and i just walk around so i like
i get some cool points but there's no
weed in it i just walked just rolled up
toilet paper yeah i put in my hat
it was more of a thing right people
would be like in street alleys and you
would be like oh there's there's some
contraband going on over there yeah and
now it's like people are just like
walking out of seven eleven lighting up
saying what's up to a [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we used to have to smoke
it like we were smoking crack in a
[ __ ] porta potty
like we're hiding in like you know what
i mean like it used to be a weird thing
where it's like oh my god is that a
joint and you're like no it's not you
know don't do drugs i remember when
you'd be driving and you'd see another
guy in a car smoking a joint
that's so illegal he should be in jail
now it's therapy now he has i have back
pain so what does that change as far as
like how the bible views it
thou shalt not smoke with it they
changed it the king the niv changed it
now the pages are him yeah yeah
ah yes oh yeah it's holy scripture if
you guys ever like when it was hella
legal here in california did you ever
dream about like one day in amsterdam
i'm gonna go to one of those cafes and
smoke weed because everyone was like
talking about it like you know in
amsterdam it's league it's legal you can
go there and then some people come back
with stories of it's everywhere you
could go in and it's legal like you
could smoke it that was totally what it
was that was literally my first trip to
amsterdam was that
was that one of the plots in a harold
and kumar movie that they want to go to
maybe euro trip or something because i
would always i feel like i faintly
remember seeing in teen movies back then
that was always like mecca
yeah because i was kind of reliving that
when i got there even though it was kind
of legal here i was like i have to do it
like i have to smoke a joint sm and
drink some coffee did you have the
holiday there no it [ __ ] sucked no
california's way california [ __ ] up
everybody but it's still pretty decent
like for the rest of europe
you know what i'm saying like i mean i'm
not saying i smoke everywhere in europe
but i'm just saying yeah you did you
said it everywhere clearly you know what
though
i i didn't get i didn't get the higher
grade i just got like uh
you know how when you get a menu that's
the cool thing is you get a menu and you
can see like oh wow
i got a lower one because i heard that
um when you get the top one that
everyone always gets it [ __ ] you up
like so much black widow or some [ __ ]
somebody when you pick it go very good
sir
very excellent or you pick badly and he
goes yeah
cafes or coffee shops or whatever
they're really just weed bars we're
always right next to actual like pastry
or donut shops and they had the weirdest
ones that like made so much sense when
you're high yeah it would be like donuts
on pizza you would come out and
you know it'd be like it would be like a
hot dog with like that was like two feet
long with nothing but cheddar and
jalapenos but then they would put like
sprinkles on it [ __ ] just didn't make
sense but made perfect sense yeah i need
to eat one of those things but europe i
think specializes a lot in like spliffs
so they mix like cigarette like tobacco
with their weed because it's like just
maybe that's what i had yeah it gets
your head high really fast but in
california everybody's like smoking
straight grass right so like any time
you try to smoke weed in europe 90 times
they're split so it's always like oh you
guys need like straight herb and they're
looking at you like you're purist
you know what i mean it's like because i
smoke three joints to myself in the in
this in the bar and i don't even usually
spliffs mixed with tobacco is that a
classier way of consuming it if it's
mixed i think it's actually a uh when
you have less weed you mix it with stuff
to make it longer right they don't have
as much weed as us yeah fentanyl
what i did think was cool though is when
we got our because we got it in joints
they had like a little cool packet that
came with the it was pre-rolled and [ __ ]
like that those are cool yeah and we had
like a ton of them so then we were just
sitting there smoking all night and i
was like you know what this ain't really
getting me that high and it's so weird
because if i i take two hits out of a
joint and i'm [ __ ] jacking off an
alley somewhere
you know like i'll have what he's having
very good sir
keep the alley open
that's a fine choice my mom keep that
alley away
it's a bunch of dudes and they're just
[ __ ] people come anywhere but the
bricks
it's a historical piece
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you